this is um cooking simulator now you may
be
looking at this oh my name is markiplier
by the way now you may be looking at
this
and you may be thinking wow markiplier
is not good
at those types of games don't call me
markiplier just call me
lexi and cut all this out cut everything
out cut cut the whole intro
just cut it out man just really cut it
out man
cut it out man let's cut it out
stop it get some help hi welcome to
cooking simulator
this is again where you cook and i know
that you might be looking at me and be
saying to yourself
wow that guy he's not good at simulator
games well
that was the old me now i'm going to try
to
really do this i should do the tutorial
because i want to take this seriously
if i was just [ __ ] around then i
might be inclined to skip over that's
the old me right old me would have gone
into
the modern mode and been so frustrated
because i didn't know how to play but
now i'm gonna play this
and i'm gonna cook me up a meal welcome
to the
welcome to cooking simulator as you've
already noticed the restaurant you're
now employed in does not have the
greatest rating
i didn't notice that at all where did
you see that did someone tell you
is this where this was oh what i wasn't
done
saving what hi i'm the manager of this
place since it's your first day i'll
show the ropes before
we start three important things you need
to know in case you get lost
lost i'm in a kitchen key bindings are
always displayed in the bottom right of
the corner during this tutorial you can
view your task in the bottom left corner
uh-huh huh looks like the last owner
left this place in a sorry state
you bought it like this oh here i go
go to the marked area hey ding dong i
need to
oh what a mess we need to get that gas
cooker running asap throw
i don't want to throw it follow the
marker take the phone
it will take ages to repair that thing
we better hire someone fast
while hovering over the cooker use
to select company then press pretty nice
corp
what what okay so if i'm thinking about
this lot
yeah you know what yep i was about to
say if i'm thinking about this logically
i should definitely not pick the
cheapest option
but when you got a sign like rape hair
i'm not gonna pick that one
how bad could it be try not to go did i
go bankrupt
almost everything in the kitchen costs
money plates products especially repairs
don't take more than you need and keep
an eye on your balance once you're out
of money you're out of business well
yeah that's why i got the cheaper pair
are they doing are they in the kitchen
repair upper of
upper oven up oven why do i have an oven
up there
oh up oven lower oh it's two ovens okay
i
see okay open
oh did i do that yep we're going cheapos
done baby oh busy well i can wait
lixian please make time go faster
okay good hey that's awesome thank you
uh repair that okay great job put the
phone away we won't be needing it
anytime soon
i hope you got it
find the cardboard boxes hover over one
and press left mouse click
to open the shop the shop the shop the
the shop the shop
oh the shop select the utensils tab and
buy a blender
okay i bought it an immersion blender
you're good now put the blender away
where do i put it away
okay it'll be faster if we move the box
hover over and press e to pick it up
and put it on the countertop why did you
put it over there why do i need to put
is this really that far away that you
can't possibly
come over here that's so far how lazy
are you i guess you bought this place
without even seeing if anything was
broken
pan good excellent excellent
is there like oh do these can these
no no no
bachelor i'm like homes uh spongebob
wow sorry sorry bud special is a little
wild
sure ah grill
i think it's hot fast oh
how do i pilot light what oh
there's fire i thought it was just gas
never mind
it's fine i'm fine we're fine
hello recipe manager okay that took me a
second click on the not owned
you're in the way buy recipe for baked
trout
did i go to cooking school is this
cooking school
but you know i could just
print it out i don't have to buy
it i could just take it you know i mean
i could just
download it legally lexington fbi is
going to break in
fbi open up okay i got it
unlocked steak and salmon steak and
boiled potatoes
okay got that tomato soup not even a
tomato bisque who
eats here i used to play a game way back
when called restaurant tycoon 2.
i really liked that game that was not
enough stuff to do this is too much
once we're open there won't be no time
for shopping best buy well we need for
now okay
bye put there for now let me just buy
them all peppered by the salt
okay pepper uh this is tea
oh this tedious shut up i'm
spicing i'm spicing it up buy listed
liquids
oh okay chicken broth that makes sense
bone broth sour cream that makes sense
i'll
keep that there i should keep these in
the fridge shouldn't i
shouldn't oh someone ordered a dish
what the hell you mean who's in here
who's in the restaurant
who opened the door you only have a
minute to come
i don't know right
what buy a trout i'm not
a trout trout but
i got a fish who are you oh
what do you mean who are you
okay let's reason this out black pepper
thyme
dried dill dried five grams of each
i know so i should put this over here i
didn't know that it
was i just put it over there
i'm trying i'm really trying to plan
this out properly okay i'm
really trying to be efficient about it
okay pepper you
four grams on this cutting board it's
gonna be delicious
damn it okay we're good jesus that was
so
that was the most stressful thing i've
ever done in my life okay
okay on the cutting board right
okay funny i heard five shakes there
weren't five shakes it put on the bake
tray
okay good thing i got the baked tree put
the baked
pin um you can use many trays at the
same time
i bet i can't how do i throw it oh no
my trout where'd my truck go
where did my trout go hello
is that true i didn't need a boy
look guys this is going great
and there's no problems because
i remember the recipe
you know what i'm not even gonna try the
bottom one
turn it on put it in
there i don't know what happened to my
other fish but that worked okay put in
the upper oven i did
i'm really trying to serve me a big trip
oh you oh it was
you you did it oh you did the thing how
dare you okay put on the cutting board
buy the cutting board miss that by that
much
uh put it here instead not like a dummy
all right now we go in oven and fit
[Music]
fish no disappear pop that bad boy on
blue
yeah okay we need lemon buy one okay
bossy [ __ ] i have a lemon brown
cutting board okay four p i should not
have a knife
how do i know oh shh
shut
shut up shut up right now
hey is my trout done uh oh
you not done yet almost there there we
go
all right bam plate buy a plate i have a
plate
oh that cost me money why did that cost
me money pop
oh it's hot oh i just burnt my hand
by plate you can transfer a health
container even when they're hot oh
good good finish it off with some
chunks chunk nice
i use lemon quarters oh
just dump them on there what is that
whoo what parsley
what who just puts lemons who just
lemons it up ding ding order up hey
you're gonna like this whole lemon click
the checkout app
we got an app for this apparently check
out there's your drought
i am a god guest
is pl perfect perfect perfect
i am a god
that's it for today we'll be open for
business tomorrow i'm
uh goodbye and for each day you'll be
presented with a summary there it is
i lost us so much c oh and please don't
go bankrupt
why are you leaving this all to me
shouldn't uh i didn't buy this why is
the financial burden on me
the tutorial is done it's not done i see
tutorial window
and she's talking let's make this the
best restaurant in the city open
right away let's get cooking what are we
opening
we need opening now i thought you might
still need me today so i'm here but only
for today i don't want you here
first order salmon steak with boiled
potatoes i need a big pot we need to
boil
where did i put my big pot oh yeah okay
we need to boil uh
oh fill it all right water i need to
boil
water right handle okay one liter
exactly
oh i did it i was so stressed
right what do you mean i got ex i did
exactly
oh huh
okay whatever i i don't understand i'm
going to put that there
i'm going to turn this on i'm going to
add this to that
and i'm going to put
oh come on fine whatever it's good
enough
all right we need to buy two potatoes
oh my god do i have to carry them one at
a time
that's the wrong burner hold big pot why
do i need to hold it
why do i need to hold it i
right salmon from the refrigerator god
you are
just a dick season with uh salt and
pepper
yeah okay
don't need to spread it evenly it's fine
frying pan with oil okay frying pan
no stop oh god boil the foil
okay we're gonna put some oil in there
why does that do like that why does that
do like that
oh don't put it precariously on the edge
if i say for 60 seconds what do you mean
what do you mean oh god i'm too late
oh sure it's uh sure i'm never gonna be
able to grab those
i need a plate plate i don't know what
plate i need wait was i supposed to heat
up the oil first
and then put the salmon in i don't know
soup what kind of lame-ass soup you eat
in there oh
okay the sauce is done i guess
[Music]
god you didn't tell me before good
i've flipped no what are you doing
don't boil the plate no what are you
doing
there we go okay i hold the plate and
then i as soon as it's done pop it on
this thing
this is actually complicated i thought
that this was going to be a bit
difficult but
i didn't think that it was going to be
this complicated
i um hang on it wasn't quite done okay
put the plate on the serving shelf use
the app to pick up the order you're
about to complete you got it buddy
order up
attack taste is complete
too much too much so what are you
talking about
it was one gram too much in the water
your taste buds are that refined that
you can detect one gram
more salt than necessary in the water
wow whatever it's fine no time for
slacking off why
next order's here who is in the
restaurant big pot make sure it's empty
well you don't want to mix it in with
the potato soup okay pour about
700 milliliters of chicken broth till
the you know where did i put the
this definitely doesn't need to be
refrigerated i don't think i don't know
here we go
yoinkas oh that is fast
i can't see your big dumb text
is in the way of my par excuse trickle
on the stove i'm guessing but what do
you it's in
they're going to detect it's too much
broth i had exactly 700 and you're
telling me that was wrong
i don't know whatever i i don't know
i can't see how much i need 12.
you got that great cayenne pepper
you got it
oh god you didn't why is that less than
the pepper
11 12. it's gonna be too peppery you
didn't tell me that
can i get more than one at a time
really this is how they do it in
restaurants they go one at a time
there's really nothing else i can do to
get more than one
at a time whoa
wait a minute i'm smart i'm
so i'm a genius oh my god
i'm so smart not all recipes call for
all products to cook
through okay so i just need the
what what needs to cook through this do
i need to put an immersion blender in
there it seems like i would need to put
an immersion blender in there okay so
i'm gonna need sour cream but afterwards
i'm gonna need
to bowl but deep plate
deep deep deep deep plate yeah they
better pay big bucks for this because
i'm losing money turn off the heat and
blend the contents of the pot okay turn
off the heat
blend
they're gonna detect just a little too
much cayenne
pepper how do i know i what
how do i how do i know
i guess i'm done oh there's one
milliliter too much
sour cream how do i oh take the pot and
aim at the bowl
i think they have like ladles or
something
oh god no not through the handle
you behemoth you behemoth
now god the handle
what am i pouring on my hands i really
do
my god there's so much soup okay good
order up
oh my god oh it's incredible they love
it and they got
a bigger portion that's what they love
the most about it technique
wrong amount of product well don't
complain that i gave you
too much [ __ ] one big trout
you'd be wrong you'd be wrong okay it's
five of
black pepper
[Music]
it was time
i said boop i think it was dill
yeah dill yeah dill definitely dill
i am a genius you open you
open on what did i leave that on or
whatever okay and lemon lemon where my
lemon go
lemon lim lip lip lip lemon let
i actually felt pretty satisfying uh
play
to basic plate i guess i should probably
set timers or something or if i was
really being meta about this and really
wanted to min max i would have timers
in real life so that i could quickly do
that instead of
fuddling with an in game
[Laughter]
what is that
you're not even done okay stay away from
the door
or else it's going to destroy everything
you love
and hold dear that trout looks done but
i don't know
hold on what
happened to you why did it fall on the
floor
order up it was not on the floor
parsley garnish damn forgot about the
garnish you're right but technique was
great okay so what's the master plan you
might ask well i want this place to go
hang on there's a plate on the floor
whatever each dish you serve affects our
fame score do well in the score goes up
mess up and we're going down
can i please i can't clean it
i did it what did i do
all right so i just need to get prep
phase
okay we're going to get inspected today
show them
there's a problem ma'am ma'am there's a
problem
they put this here because they knew
that their game
made this happen they knew and it's not
like in a real kitchen you stand too
close to the oven and suddenly a plate
gets completed
i need to put my game face on i have a
food critic
to impress appetite's coming through
that door and he's gonna have a big ego
i left this on overnight that almost
tried to kill me
ding order up okay salmon steak okay
easy i know salmon steak i need to put a
pan
it's already oiled hopper on there [ __ ]
and boiled potatoes easy i got her i got
the potato broth
going push some potatoes in there bunk
bunk
bloom bloom easy it's gonna be slightly
too salty
but that's okay oh i didn't season it
right right right
i can season while it cooks there's
nothing wrong with that yeah i do that
in real life there's no reason why i
shouldn't work in a game right
time to flippy dip if i remember how to
do this all right okay
all right okay okay okay now shift
rumpus that's not at all
pick up pick it up
what are you doing what are you doing
why are you crawling away
advanced controls rotate oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god okay i did it
they're gonna love it they're gonna love
it plate serve it hot oh it's
it's gonna be hot all right and
[Music]
this critic's gonna love it
and they did not enough
so
oh that wasn't the food okay well screw
that person okay
uh it's a shame us in front of the food
yeah i can't shame us in front of the f
we'll screw you i don't know man pork
chops all right porky choppies
season with salt you got it all right
easy peasy
two three four okay uh black pepper four
not five four just because it's gotta be
weird
time time dill
i should bring these over here you
should be here
six i put
okay six add sunflower oil to a pan
let me just rinse this
and then rotate
get it out get out the hole i want to
throw it okay good got it it's empty
30 milliliter in there
very gently
perfect i'm getting good at that i'm by
good at that i mean i have a heart
attack
every time 90 seconds that he said got
it
okay now potatoes how many potatoes 300
grams how much is one potato is it oh
two potatoes okay two potatoes oh i
forgot about that
put it on there it'll be fine don't move
when you
ah
why would i want oh why would i want to
put
anything ever on the floor why
would i ever want to put anything
choppas choppas how was i supposed to do
this as
into chunks okay it just said chunks
chunky that's chunky i need to flip
let's flip you boinkis okay and gently
confidently put these on to try all
okay put it down okay how much six okay
okay six done pop it in the oven i am
so stressed porkchop's doing good i
don't know how long the potatoes take in
the oven
god and i know for a fact this is ev
this is just a fraction
of how stressful an actual kitchen could
be but my god it's okay what kind of
plate we looking at ain't garnish oh
50 gram chunks i did not see that oh
shoot what's gonna be done first
[Music]
definitely
how you doing hey good to see you no one
tell me this was on the floor the
seasonings looked disgusting
oh my god oh my god
oh my god damn it
how are you not done yet oh jesus oh my
god
if i was in the bottom one it wouldn't
be doing that oh no
all done all done all done put it on the
plate pile it on there
it said 300 grams of potatoes
it did 300 grams this is 300 grams of
potatoes order
up baby order up
phenomenal how does this plus this equal
that
not enough so you cannot
have both too much salt and not enough
salt
you can't
you cannot have both
too much salt and not enough salt
happens okay it happens it was
perfect temperature-wise and they have
no idea it fell on the floor
okay so that was
really something i tried really hard i
actually tried and i succeeded despite
what anyone may
think i actually succeeded in that i did
everything that i needed to
i was perfect the whole way through and
i made some delicious food
that the critic was too stupid to
understand the greatness of so thank you
everybody so much for watching this has
been cooking simulator
i doubt that i'll ever come back to this
but write in the comments if you'd like
to feudally shout into the void
that i should play it again because it's
just too stressful
unless i could build an empire and be
the greatest chef that ever lived but
until that day comes
i will stick to cooking in my own house
and moderately risking burning my house
down every time i do so thank you
everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you